nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
le 24 février dernier Vladimir Poutine
l'ancêtre en Ukraine selon la
terminologie officielle russe une
opération militaire spéciale de des
nazification et des militarisations une
guerre qui ne dit pas son nom par ces
termes Vladimir Poutine écrit un mythe
moderne qu'il impose non seulement à sa
propre population mais aussi à celle des
territoires occupés où les Russes
s'érigent libérateur et en héros une
inversion des rôles sur fond de massacre
et d'exaction qui valent aujourd'hui à
l'armée et aux propagandistes russes une
enquête ouverte par le parquet ukrainien
pour génocide et incitation au génocide
notre reporter elena bolochine est allé
à la rencontre des populations dans les
territoires libérés par l'armée
ukrainienne pour comprendre comment la
réalité parallèle de Vladimir Poutine y
est mis en place et orchestrée
Ukraine sous l'occupant c'est un
reportage d'elenavechine pour France 24
[Musique]
des rescapés de l'occupation russe nous
sentons toujours les mêmes histoires
[Musique]
celle d'un régime de terreur est une
réalité parallèle imposée par les forces
de Vladimir Poutine
la propagande des médiasetarus
transposés au réel dans les territoires
occupés
nous sommes venus là-bas pour libérer
les Ukrainiens de ce malheur que sont
les nazis qui ont mis toute l'Ukraine à
leur bottes
ne date pas d'hier en 2014 déjà la
propagande russe Martelet que des nazis
Ukrainiens interdiraient torusophones
d'Ukraine de par les Russes et se livrer
un génocide
on nous demande à quel point c'est
dangereux d'être riche aujourd'hui en
Ukraine c'est à peu près aussi dangereux
que d'être juif en Allemagne en mai 33
nous défendrons nos citoyens par tous
les moyens dont nous disposons
8 ans plus tard Vladimir Poutine lance
ce qu'il qualifie de des nazification de
l'Ukraine avec des méthodes pour le
moins radicales
isum région de kerki libéré depuis moins
de deux semaines
les Ukrainiens ont décidé d'exumer tous
les corps enterrés durant les six mois
d'occupation russe dans cette forêt
450 tombes et une fausse commune
17 cordes des forces armées ukrainiennes
l'un d'entre eux avec les mains liées
derrière le dos
les autres tombes sont individuels mais
on a trouvé des tombes qui contenaient
deux ou trois ans
d'après les premières observations des
médecins légistes la plupart des morts
seraient Dieu aux mines et au
bombardement
mais certains corps portent aussi des
traces d'exaction
les membres d'une délégation officielle
lituanienne en visite au cimetière sont
invités à constater
le crâne a été fracturé
de façon préliminaire on peut dire que
c'est une balle traversante elle est
entrée par l'arrière de la tête est
sorti par le côté on n'a pas retrouvé
les pieds les mains aussi sont séparées
du corps qui porte un treillis militaire
des militarisation l'autre objectif de
guerre déclarée de Vladimir Poutine
à 20 ans Yann en famille d'accueil dont
le grand-père et garde forestier en a
fait les frais lorsque les Russes sont
entrés dans son village
ils ont trouvé dans les tiroirs de mon
grand-père à compas et sa carte de garde
forestier je suis apprenti
garde-forestiers aussi et ils ont trouvé
ma tenue de camouflage il pensait que
mon grand-père et moi étions des
pointeurs dans l'artillerie
sac sur la tête main liée derrière le
dos Yann et son grand-père sont emmenés
passés à tabac et torturer
un couteau sur ma tête il disait on va
te couper les doigts on va te couper la
tête et on va jouer au football avec il
menaçait de me couper le sexe
ils ont ramené un journal l'ont allumé
et ont mis le feu à mon entrejambe il
répétait sans arrêt tu es un nazi je lui
disais je ne suis pas un nazi il me
répondait tais-toi je vais te mettre un
coup de cross dans les dents
pour eux tous les Ukrainiens étaient des
nazis
après les avoir enlevés les soldats
russes se sont installés dans la maison
du grand-père la famille ne peut plus y
revenir
il ne reste que des ruines il n'y a plus
de maison impossible de la reconstruire
ils ont tout emporté absolument tout le
réfrigérateur et la machine à laver
était neufs
de nos maisons de notre liberté ils nous
ont libérés de tout
pas prononcer le mot
occupation c'était totalement interdit
ils sont des libérateurs
la mère d'accueil de Yann connaît bien
cette propagande en 2014 elle a fui
gorlifa dans la région de Donetsk après
la main mise de la Russie sur ce bout de
territoire à l'est de l'Ukraine là-bas
les Russes l'ont largement diffusé tout
comme ici dans la région de kerkiff
durant l'occupation
un cauchemar depuis 2014
et voilà les nazis c'est comme ça qu'il
nous voyait
à partir de 2014 c'était un cauchemar
ils interdisaient aux gens de parler
russe c'est faux je parle russe jusqu'à
maintenant ceux qui disaient du bien de
la Russie étaient battus et enlevé c'est
faux ça fait 8 ans que je vis ici
personne ne m'a jamais battu
pour la plupart ce sont des fascistes
voilà
[Musique]
une forme de mythologie basée sur des
contre-vérités dont la Russie veut
persuader non seulement sa propre
opinion publique mais aussi celle des
territoires occupés
les nazis mettent une vigueur
particulière à raser la ville russe de
Mario Paul qui s'est soulevé en 2014
contre le coup d'État de maïdan il a
sacrifie volontairement car cette ville
n'est pas à eux au nationalisme après la
prise sanglante de Mario Paul qualifiée
elle aussi de libération par la
propagande russe sur place les occupants
c'est riches en héros
Mario Paul libérez résonne des bruits de
chantier le but est avant tout de
déplier les décombres dans les quartiers
habités des centaines de sauveteurs sont
venus de toute la rue des écrans mobiles
comme celui-ci sont apparus dans les
rues de la ville ils transmettent les
chaînes de télévision russe
lorsqu'on a déployé pour la première
fois ce type de véhicule il y avait un
reportage sur la libération de l'usine à
l'ophtales et le retour de la vie
Pacifique à Marie-Paule les gens se sont
mis à applaudir et leurs larmes ont
coulé ça veut dire que ce qu'on fait est
bien
dans le monde réel à une autre ville
dévastée par les bombes et occupés
pendant 6 mois par la Russie
les employés du département de
l'éducation de la mairie retrouvent pour
la première fois leur locaux depuis la
Libération
leur bureau ont été mis à ça et tous les
disques durs du département ont disparu
ça nous fait vraiment de la peine tout
fonctionner tellement bien et maintenant
il va falloir tout recommencer à zéro
toutes vos
services comptable du département de
l'éducation
la plupart des documents papiers ont été
détruits et tous les ordinateurs ont été
démontés toute l'information a disparu
je n'imagine même pas ce qu'on doit
faire pour restaurer tout ça
ces fonctionnaires ont tout juste pu
retrouver quelques manuels et supports
pédagogiques
stockées dans un hangar
pauvre ils ont sorti tous les livres de
nos établissements tous les manuels en
Ukrainiens avec lesquels nos enfants
étudiés
je suppose qu'il voulait introduire leur
propre manuel tout ce qui était à nous
il le détruisait il le prenait et il le
détruisait tout simplement ici c'est ce
qu'on a réussi à sauver
les manuels et les programmes scolaires
Ukrainiens par des manuels et des
programmes russes
une priorité de l'opération spéciale
dite de dénazification
Victoria et professeur d'histoire elle a
fut l'occupation de son village au nord
de berdance qui était dernier depuis
avec ses autres collègues en exil il
tente de poursuivre l'enseignement à
distance pour les élèves rester sur
place qui suivent leur courbe de façon
clandestine
aujourd'hui ils vont
n'importe quelle maison et vérifier tout
ce qu'ils veulent parce qu'ils viennent
avec des armes alors on ne peut pas leur
dire quoi que ce soit ils préviennent
ils menace ils interdisent ils effacent
il confisquait les appareils numériques
là-bas aussi il y avait deux enseignants
qui comme nous continuaient l'école
ukrainienne à distance et ils ont été
kidnappés aujourd'hui personne ne sait
où il se trouve
pendant que nous filmons Victoria reçoit
justement un appel
elle est professeur d'anglais un autre
enseignant a été emmené par les soldats
il y a 2 jours elle dit que personne ne
sait rien sa femme il voulait qu'il soit
directeur de l'école
avant de fuir son village Victoria a été
convoqué avec ses collègues le chef
militaire russe de la nouvelle
administration locale voulait qu'il
travaille pour son école
Victoria a pu enregistrer cette
conversation
[Musique]
le militaire qui nous a contrôlé au
point de passage depuis les territoires
occupés lui aussi m'a dit comment
pouvez-vous ignorer cela chez nous à
Moscou nous avons des documents à la
bibliothèque qui prouvent que l'Ukraine
n'aurait jamais existé sans les lignes
c'est comme ça qu'ils nous traitait
comme des petits russes comme si on
faisait partie de l'empire russe notre
état aurait été créé par Lénine et avant
cela nous n'aurions existé qu'au sein de
l'Empire russe
un exposé mot pour mot de la doctrine
négationniste dictée par Vladimir
Poutine à la société russe
le parquet ukrainien a ouvert une
enquête pour génocide et incitations au
génocide menées par un procureur du
département de la sûreté d'État
c'est
une copie de la couverture du livre
d'Armen Gasparian des nazifications de
l'Ukraine le pays des leçons non retenu
ce livre parle de comment exterminer les
Ukrainiens il fait la malgae entre le
nationalisme et le nazisme prétend que
l'Ukraine n'est pas un état indépendant
que nous ne sommes ni une nation ni un
peuple
en 2018 ce livre édité en 2017 a
officiellement été acheté par
l'administration du président de la
Fédération de Russie
d'après l'enquête ukrainienne le
discours prononcé par Vladimir Poutine à
la veille de l'invasion repose sur une
idéologie génocidaire construite sur
plusieurs années
d'après les conclusions de l'expertise
il contient des incitations à des
actions systématiques violentes ils ont
apprivé les ukrainiens et la nation
ukrainienne de leur identité en tant que
groupe national unique à les privés de
leur conscience propre de leur identité
nationale et de leur aspiration en état
de fait il appelle à ané tout ce qui est
ukrainien
russes et de leur commandement ces idées
sont devenues réalités
quel est l'impact réel de cette
propagande sur l'état d'esprit des
Russes qui combattent en Ukraine
[Musique]
nous avons pu joindre le chef russe
d'une société militaire privée sous
contrat avec le ministère de la Défense
il a passé 6 mois d'occupation à hésium
c'est un pays prostitué et leur nation
est pareil ils sont tous comme ça sans
exception des enfants au plus vieux pour
tout ce qu'ils ont fichu manigancé pour
ça ils vont tous être exterminés il n'en
restera que de la terre brûlée l'homme
ni en bloc les exactions dont on accuse
les Russes mais promet la vengeance il
vous raconte des histoires pour qu'on
les plaigne qu'on leur donne de l'argent
de l'aide humanitaire pour qu'on les
montre à la télévision
quand nous reviendrons nous leur ferons
exactement ce qu'il vous raconte c'est
fini parce que quand on est gentil il ne
comprennent pas
la gentillesse des Russes vaut
aujourd'hui à Michael Phoenix des
séances de psychothérapie
la balle est entrée par le côté il y
avait une déchirure et elle est
ressortie tout droit quand lui et son
épouse fuyait leur village les occupants
ont ouvert le feu sur la colonne de
véhicules civils
tout le long de la route il y avait des
cadavres personne ne les ramassait car
il tirait sans arrêt
sur 3 km de long il y avait des
véhicules calcinés et des cadavres
cette psychothérapeute ukrainienne
travaille pour une ONG américaine elle
tente de venir en aide au réchapper des
zones de combat et de la réalité
parallèle du monde russe
de tuer un être humain pour une cause
qui n'existe pas dans la réalité
son esprit doit trouver une explication
à cela si en plus la personne n'a pas
accès à d'autres informations
elle doit puiser dans son stock de
ressources pour résister à cela et avec
le temps ces ressources vont s'épuiser
et cela deviendra de plus en plus dur
on trouve peut-être l'un des buts
d'explication à l'emprise de la
propagande de Vladimir Poutine sur les
esprits en Russie
quant au territoire occupés ce qui n'est
pas accepté de gré est imposé par la
force
partout où passe les Russes les
témoignages de crimes de guerre se
multiplient
voilà pour cette enquête en Ukraine
signée Elena Volochine de France 24
c'est la fin de ce magazine merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
reporter
[Musique]